Speaker 1: All right. It is time for the Friday
mailbag and what a mailbag it is. If you have
something to say, you can email info at David
Pakman dot com. Respectful messages are always
preferred, but they can be about absolutely
anything that's on your mind. So let's start
today with Vincent. Vincent is, as usual, not
happy with me and he's not happy with juice. And
okay. So Vincent says, why would any Jew or black
be in favor of gun control? If I were a member of
a group that was put in danger of extermination
as the Jews were by thirties and forties Germany,
I would never give up my arms. Similarly, the very
first Jim Crow laws passed after reconstruction
were laws prohibiting the ownership of firearms
by blacks. If someone ever enslaved me,
I would never turn over my guns. An armed person
is a citizen. An unarmed person is a potential
slave. So this is this this particular email
is not overtly anti-Semitic, this Vincent guy.
Every email is about Jews one way or the other. He
can't send an email without mentioning Jews. But
to the point here, first of all, there's two sides
to this. Number one, the whole concept of if the
Jews had guns in Germany, there would have been
no holocaust. It has been studied extensively by
historians and it has been widely debunked. It is
not true that if Jews had handguns in Germany or
even rifles in Germany right before the Holocaust,
that it would have prevented it. And similarly, in
the United States, when folks think handguns and
a AR 15 are going to prevent government tyranny,
if it really came to it with the tanks and the
Blackhawk helicopters and the shoulder mounted
RPGs, it's not so either the argument doesn't make
sense or you're saying citizens should be able to
own those arms. Or, you know, I've actually
talked to Ben SHAPIRO about this, and you can
find that conversation on our YouTube channel.
But the second piece is the following one.
I am sensitive to the idea that government tyranny
aside, is it really good if only the right wing
nuts have the guns? And that's why many of my
liberal friends are now firearms owners. And
as I've said before, I don't talk about my own
ownership or lack thereof of firearms. But there
are many people I know who say I don't even really
like guns, but I don't want only the right wing
nuts to have them. And it's it is it is sort of
a race to the bottom. That's the sad thing about
it. Next email is from Nathan. Nathan writes in
about the Overton Window and says, David, sir,
are you familiar with the Overton Window? This
concept seems to be the reason why Pence has been
characterized as saving democracy by simply doing
his job. Opposed to Trump's insanity. It's similar
to the concept I've heard you describe before as
hyper normalization. Adam Curtis rocks too. This
concept is very hard to work into conversations
with the Trump supporters in my life. Any tips
to deal much love from a very red upstate New York
area? Yeah, I've been I've been spending more and
more time in upstate New York. It is shockingly
right wing. And, you know, when you look at New
York as a state, it's very blue, but that it's
extremely skewed by the city and a few other a few
other spots. But I've spent a lot of time lately,
like in the Hudson area and right in in Hudson
it's quite blue, but everywhere around. I haven't
looked at the maps, but it looks very deep red.
You know, Joe Biden has dementia lawn signs
and all sorts of different stuff. But yes,
it is absolutely true that when the
Republican Party has lost its mind,
when Mike Pence says, I can't overturn the result,
some people go, what a hero, what a pro-democracy
hero he is. When Liz Cheney says, hey, Joe Biden
really won and Trump incited the January six riot,
we go, Wow, what a heroic, reasonable Republican,
because in comparison they seem that way. But
these are not heroes. These are just some of the
few. Cut somewhat attached to reality voices that
remain in the Republican Party. Neil wrote in
about my Alex Jones impression, and Neil says,
David, since you asked, I don't really like your
Alex Jones impression. Not because it isn't very
good, but because as a person with a lisp I cringe
heavily when people fake lisp. To me it seems your
impression is just a heavy lisp, not a heavy
smoker, as the caller mentioned. Anyway, love
the show. Yeah. Is that even a lisp? Like when?
When Alex Jones says globalists? I don't think
of that as a lisp. I think of a lisp as something
else. Where, anyway, I'm not I'm not going to even
mimic it now. We're not making fun of Lisp. We're
not doing any of it. We're not doing any of it.
That being said, there is this thing I don't know
if it's a list, but I don't know if you guys have
noticed that Don Junior and Ivanka. They seem to
have fake teeth that are a little bit too big for
them and it makes them speak in a weird way. I
don't think that's a lisp either. Maybe I just
don't know enough about what counts as a lisp.
But anyway, we're certainly not making fun of
lists here on the show. Thank you, Neal. Jillian
wrote in about fuel prices. Gillian says fuel
prices have an impact on cost of living. That's
undeniable, but it amazes me that Americans cannot
see the whole picture. For a long time now, the
low cost of fuel in the U.S. has been an enviable
luxury, as seen from other countries. Now prices
have risen across the world. In fact, in Ghana,
where I currently live, the price of a gallon
of diesel has rocketed to 717 or 595 a gallon,
depending on whether you use UK or USA gallons.
This is in a country where many live well below
the poverty line and this price rise has extreme
effects. I sympathize with all people who are
suffering at the moment, not just those in one
country. Yes. So one of the things we have to
acknowledge is it can both be true that paying for
50 a gallon instead of 250 a gallon in the United
States is a major impact on a lot of families.
That's true. And also, prices in the U.S. for fuel
are really low compared to the rest of the world
for the most part, other than some extremely,
you know, oil producing rich nations. I think
like in the Emirates or Gap, fuel is really cheap.
But that's because fuel prices in the U.S. have
not been accurate in terms of representing the
true cost of fuel fuel. Gasoline prices are
subsidized in the U.S. and the production
is subsidized. So what that means is there's a
lot of environmental and sorry, the production
is subsidized and the environmental impact is not
accurately reflected by the prices that we pay. So
we are not accurately charging the end user for
gasoline and diesel. That's that's the truth in
the United States. And when when gas prices more
accurately reflect their full cost, including on
the environment, people drive much smaller,
fuel efficient vehicles. When I was in Spain,
about somewhere between a month and ten years ago,
I don't know. It's a blur. No, I think last summer
when I was in Spain. Last summer, yeah. Ten,
nine, ten months ago, I rented a relatively fuel
efficient vehicle. I don't even remember what it
was. There's all these little vehicles that they
have in Europe that we don't have here in the
U.S.. Stick shift, little hatchback and quite
fuel efficient. And it was still really expensive
to drive around because I don't you know, you have
to convert euro to dollar and you have to convert
liters, two gallons and do a whole thing. I think
it was roughly seven something a gallon and just
doing a reasonable amount of driving still costs a
bunch. The tolls are very high. Driving around is
much more accurately priced in Europe and in other
parts of the world. So 100% Gillian is correct.
Gersson wrote in about David Beard man and says,
Hello, David, I am writing this to implore you
to grow out your beard. I see limitless potential
in your facial hair. Clean up the neckline. Set
your follicles free. I assure you, you will have
elegant whiskers in no time. Use jojoba oil and
a beard balm of your choice to keep everything
healthy and moisturized. A boar hair brush is also
a worthwhile investment. Sincerely, a man with a
similar beard. Yeah. You know, what happened was
when the baby came and then I had the, you know,
the unexpected time off and all these different
things. I just didn't have time to shave. Last
night I did. I did a little cleanup, and I cleaned
up the neckline and everything. I am willing to
get creative with the beard. That is that is not
something I am afraid of. Let's see where it goes.
Fletch wrote in and says, Why not arm the military
with baseball bats and knives? Sir. A common
argument I'm coming across from the right is that
knives and baseball bats can kill. Yet we have no
restrictions on those. So why have restrictions on
guns? In that case, why not send the troops into
battle only with knives and baseball bats? Surely
if a bat is just. As lethal as a high powered
rifle. Then purchasing said rifles for the troops
is a waste of taxpayer dollars, of course. Yeah,
I mean, it's sort of tongue in cheek, but there
is some sense to that. If it were true that knives
and baseball bats and hammers and all these
things are potentially just as deadly as guns,
then why waste all the money on guns for
the military and for police? Yes. Now,
there are some pretty easy holes to poke in that.
But it is a fair question to be asking regardless.
Philip writes in and says, What's the controversy
over the word expat? David The following question
is in regards to a response of yours about how
to identify Ukraine on the YouTube video entitled
Trump on his Knees for Jesus. That that's a
great video. As an expat living in Thailand,
I did not know there was a controversy surrounding
the term expat. Could you explain it again?
So here's the deal with the term expat. I
have two answers to this. On the one hand,
the reason the term expat has gotten controversial
is that there is a sort of like racialized class
element to it. And I'll explain it to you. When
someone from Thailand comes to the United States.
We rarely call them ex-pats. We call them
immigrants. And when an American goes to Thailand,
we often don't say, I'm an immigrant. People say
I'm an expat. So I think you can understand how
implicit in that there's potentially a class and
a race element to it. But but I also want to go
further sometimes when the white dude, you know,
assuming Philip is an American white dude, when
the white dude goes to Thailand, they're not going
and finding work in the local economy. They're
either going already as sort of semi-retired or
they're going and working a remote American job
and earning U.S. dollars while in Thailand.
That's different than someone from Thailand
who comes to the United States and and has to
find work, let's call it like non professional,
like not a doctor that comes to the U.S. to
become a doctor from China. But people in the
service industry and so on the one hand, there's
this kind of race class thing where when the
Americans go elsewhere, we call them expats. And
when people from other countries come to the U.S.,
we call them immigrants. Sometimes there is a
difference, which is you go in, you're, you know,
a remote worker for a tech company in Thailand.
And that's a little bit different because
your relationship to the Thai economy is then
something other than when someone comes to the
U.S. and works like in the service industry. So
I think that there are differences between types
of immigration. And that's the controversy that
exists over the term expat. Here's a few bonuses
Jesse commented on YouTube. Dear David Pakman, you
have never needed a gun and you have no right to
speak about guns. Well, number one saying I have
no right to speak. That doesn't sound like you
support free speech. I have no right to speak.
But this is very dumb. This is like saying if
you've not been in the military, you can't have
an opinion about the Iraq war. We heard some
right wingers saying that during George W Bush's
Iraq war. That's silly. And also, you have never
needed a gun. I have chosen not to talk about
my personal relationship to guns on the show,
including my ownership or lack of ownership of
firearms. So I think it's neither here nor there.
But you don't know anything about my relationship
to guns. Okay, Jesse, thank you very much.
Another YouTube comment. No cap. But I honestly
thought Pacman was like 26 or 27 years old,
tops. Please share your skin care routine,
David. Okay, here's my skincare routine.
I use face lotion with SPF 15. I just use it.
Okay, so when I'm out there, I've got sunscreen.
Summer, winter, spring, fall. I've got SPF. And
then otherwise, that's really it. I use a vitamin
C cleanser in the shower. Thank you very much.
And lastly from John. John says, People wake
up. Mr. Pacman is our enemy. Mr. Pacman hates
the common American. I wonder why he didn't
talk about Biden's mental health. I've actually
talked about it many times. Also, why did he not
talk about Biden stopping the feds from dealing
with the virus and making it the state's problem?
What funny wasn't that Biden's big campaign
promise to end the virus? What the hell,
Pacman? How much is Big Pharma and George Soros
giving you to give us propaganda? Nothing. I bet
your life you are a millionaire from them,
not from the common American. Your wife. You
are a sellout. And people are beginning to
see this. I couldn't possibly address that
in the way in which it should substantively
be addressed. So let me do a presented without
comment. Thank you very much to everybody who
wrote in info at David Pakman dotcom bonus show
coming up. Just me on today's bonus show. No, Pat,
Pat's gone, but you'll get me for better or worse.
Sign up at join pacman dot com. Otherwise,
we'll see you after the July 4th holiday.